قراراته طالبان المثيره للجدل قد تدفع
بمنظمه الامم المتحده الى مغادره البلاد
فالمنظمه الامميه اطلقت مراجعه لعملياتها
في افغانستان وطلبت من جميع الموظفين
الافغان عدم القدوم الى العمل على الاقل
حتى شهر مايو المقبل والسبب وراء هذه
الخطوه هو قرار طالبان منع الموظفات
الافغانيات من العمل مع المنظمه بعدما كنا
قد منعنا من قبل للعمل مع جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه هذا واتهمت البعثه الاماميه
بافغانستان طالبان بارغامها على التخلي عن
الشعب الافغاني وهو ما يتعارض مع مبادئ
المنظمه كما شددتها المنظمه على ان
السلطات طالبان تتحمل اي عواقب سلبيه
لتبعات قراراتها على الشعب الافغاني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على
يوتيوبر للاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات